c'est un parti ouvertement anti système
qui se fait une place dans le paysage
politique portugais rompant ainsi le
champ de la droite traditionnelle en
recueillant près d'un demi million de
voir le parti d'extrême droite d'andré
ventouras est arrivé en troisième
position lors de ces élections une
percée inédite dans un pays faisant
encore figure d'exception en europe pour
avoir jusque là échappé au phénomène
populiste à la tête de son parti chega
qui signifie ça suffit andré ventouras
s'impose comme un leader crédible pour
asseoir la droite populiste dans le pays
il s'agit d'une nuit historique au cours
de laquelle la droite portugaise est
complètement remaniée une union
historique au cours de laquelle pour la
première fois un parti anti système
assumer à briser le spectre de la droite
traditionnelle avec environ un demi
million de voix et a réussi à casser la
barrière habituel pour créer une force
anti système écrasante provocateur on
dre ventouras avait créé la stupeur en
se faisant une place au parlement lors
des élections législatives de 2010 9
marquant ainsi le retour de l'extrême
droite au parlement portugais pour la
première fois depuis la chute de la
dictature en 1974
juriste de formation fervent catholique
le leader surnommé le train portugais
est un véritable produit médiatique
surfant sur la controverse amateurs de
stendhal comme lorsqu'il demande à une
députée noire défendant la restitution
d'oeuvres d'art à d'anciennes colonies
d'être elle même rendue à son pays
d'origine le leader enchaîne les propos
polémiques
une recette qui semble fonctionner on
l'a gagné beaucoup dans visibilité
beaucoup de couverture médiatique il ya
eu de l'intérêt pour ce candidat andré
20 tours 1 a profité d'un
affaiblissement des partis de la droite
traditionnelle encore pénalisé par la
cure d'austérité qui l'ont imposé aux
portugais après la crise de la dette en
2011 ses dernières avancées dans
l'échiquier politique portugais est
fortement soutenue en europe avec parmi
ses alliés
le populiste italien matteo salvini ou
encore marine le pen qui s'est affichée
avec lui lors de sa campagne
je pense qu'il faut qu'il peut offrir
aux portugais et au portugal à un choix
patriotique qui à mon avis était jusqu'à
présent inexistant un choix patriotique
avec au programme une politique anti
avortement une lutte contre le marxisme
culturel et le politiquement correct en
dhr event aura affirme souhaiter changer
le système en profondeur un système
auquel il appartient malgré lui ses
opposants pointent du doigt ces
incohérences mais pour andré ventouras
l'objectif est clair continuer à faire
parler de lui
[Musique]